Speaker 1: It's time for the weekly mailbag
if you have something you want to say to me
and many of you do.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
Please don't abuse it, but you can do that.
Let's get right in.
We're going to start with a very, very ugly
message.
This one actually came in via Facebook.
This was a response to our clip last week
about evolution.
You might remember that Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker last week said If
evolution is real, why are there still monkeys?
And we talked about that last week.
Now, this viewer wrote to me very angry, making
the following Counterpoint Think about water.
Were did it came from or did it also evolved?
And, you know, I never have considered the
evolution of water in this entire crazy thing
we called life, I don't I don't have an answer
to that.
This person also went on two hours later to
write and say as a follow up in all caps,
Jehovah is the name of the creator.
Whether you believe it or not, just because
you may not like it doesn't mean is not true.
So quite a diatribe from the standpoint of
the evolution of water.
And this, of course, a reminder that education
is really a problem in the United States.
If we had a solution to the education problem,
we would be much better off politically.
We would be much better off culturally and
we would be much better off economically,
I would argue.
So there it is the evolution of water, not
something I had thought about before.
John Roden and John said, Hey, Pacman or Pacman,
whatever.
I am expressing my opinion here as a viewer.
You have a horrible, stupid show.
Stop broadcasting now, stop wasting your time.
Get a real life and grow up.
I actually I love these emails.
And the reason I love these emails and I know
there are people in our audience who like
the show and who are miserable in their jobs,
and I don't take any pleasure in that I like
that makes me feel bad.
I want everybody to have a job they like,
and that's sustainable financially in all
these different things.
One of the things I love is people who are
very clearly not satisfied with their own
lives.
Write to me and say, You got to get a real
job.
You got to.
You got to get a real life.
You've got to grow up, etc.
This job is fine.
I love the hours.
I'm very satisfied with the salary.
I'm very satisfied with the meaning of what
I'm doing.
And it's just so funny to hear from other
people who are clearly miserable in their
lives, which in many cases, is what causes
them to lash out at random people on the internet
that they don't know.
There's something funny about them saying
to me, You got to get your life together together,
kid.
So anyway, thank you, John.
I appreciate the message.
OK?
P. Samuels wrote in.
This is the last negative one.
Then we're going to go to a positive and substantive
stuff.
I very seldom write to shows on TV or otherwise.
I guess I'm lucky in that way.
David Pakman is a true low IQ imbecile.
Do a solid favor and ask him to keep his mouth
shut.
There is so much dribble coming forth from
his mouth.
It is beyond disgusting.
Well, thank you, sir.
I will keep that in mind.
I guess I should really reconsider this show.
It seems like at least two people very, very
much don't like it.
That's P Samuels.
All right.
Let's get into some other stuff.
Oh, sorry, I apologize.
There's one more negative one and this this.
So here's the point with this one.
We covered Trump's last rally.
Excuse me, choking here, I'm going to take
a sip of water.
We covered Trump's last rally in South Carolina,
and I mentioned on Twitter that Trump was
particularly disheveled, slurring, confused.
Both eyes almost completely swollen shape,
and it seemed that a lot of his followers
realized that was not a great performance,
but they decided to take it out on me.
They were furious with me for my commentary
on the rally.
Newport wrote to me and said about the rally.
David, you are disgusting.
You were an arrogant, ignorant fool sucking
up to the likes of Nancy Pelosi, Chuck Schumer,
the squad and the rest of the socialist elite
in Washington.
Now what I love about that is I'm not a fan
of Nancy Pelosi's.
I can't remember the last time I spoke about
Chuck Schumer.
I can't remember the last time I praised the
squad.
And I'm not a socialist, so I actually don't
know what this person's talking about.
It doesn't matter.
Here's the amazing part of the email I watched
the Trump rally.
The man is brilliant.
You are an idiot and a fool, and you're snide.
Little snippets during the president's presentation
exuded and reeked of your ignorance and arrogance.
Go drown yourself in the swamp of Washington,
D.C.
I have never watched your show, had never
even heard of you until I watched this rally
on your channel, and I will never ever in
the history of the world.
Watch you again.
You are a sick man.
Here's what I would say to you, sir.
Anyone who believes Trump is brilliant should
not like my show, I would consider it a problem.
I would be concerned if someone who thinks
Trump is brilliant liked what I was doing
it.
I consider it.
Praise it is confirmation that I'm doing something
right that people who think Trump is brilliant
don't like me.
That's a great thing.
Thank you, sir.
I appreciate that.
OK, David wrote in with some ideas for an
alternative to screed.
Back in February, I would often describe Trump's
unhinged rants as febrile screeds.
David wrote in and said, I've noticed you
keep referring to various wacky or delusional
rants by right wing politicians as screeds,
for example, Donald Trump's latest febrile
screed.
Perhaps a distinction without a difference,
but technically screed refers to a written
rant.
Not a spoken one.
As you mean to say, there are a number of
alternatives you can test out, including diatribe,
tirade and polemic.
In all seriousness, thanks for calling out
the buffoonery of these right wing radicals
when they issue such febrile screeds with
peace and love.
Yeah, I had something like four March since
it has an M. I think I was.
It was a manic.
What was it manic?
I don't remember now, anyway, I'll work on
something else, maybe a.
Maybe a delusional diatribe would be some
appropriate alliteration.
Another David wrote in Dave, who says, David,
you mentioned that the democracy rating of
Ukraine is 60 and Russia is 20.
Where does the United States fit on this same
scale?
So that particular ranking was from the Freedom
House.
And in that Freedom House index, the U.S.
ranks at an 82 on the Democracy Rank ranking.
So in that one, it's U.S. aid to Ukraine 60,
Russia 20.
Now, I think that there is a case to be made
that in the United States, people are less
free than in some other countries in a particular
way.
And that is the ability to live your life
the way you want without worrying about having
medical coverage.
That's not typically considered in most of
these kind of like freedom and democracy rankings.
I would argue and I would argue it very strongly
that if you know that no matter what you do,
you have medical care, you are more free to
pursue a passion that may not come with health
insurance and the job that you would tend
to have to have to get health insurance.
You are free to stay home and raise children
without having to worry about will I have
health insurance?
So that's not typically part of these freedom
and democracy rankings.
I believe it should be because in countries
where you are guaranteed health care, regardless
of your job, you are more free.
In a sense, although I understand that it's
a little bit different than issues of corruption
and the like.
But in the Freedom House index, the U.S. ranks
at 82.
Compared to Ukraine 60 and Russia 20, Brian
writes in and says, I have enjoyed watching
some of your YouTube pieces.
I have a suggestion, say electoral instead
of electoral.
See what you think.
Keep calm and carry on.
So I again, I look this up, and this is going
to relate to a later, a later email.
I am finding that both pronunciations electoral
and electoral are both appropriate.
Electoral comes more naturally to me, and
I don't know if it's that I speak English
as a second language or what, but electoral
just feels more natural.
OK, Sherry wrote in asking, Is the White House
beautiful or is it a dump?
David, go back and look at videos from when
Trump first won in 2016 and went to the White
House.
He called the White House a dump.
Now he says, it's beautiful.
The beautiful White House.
What a schmuck he is.
As bad as Hitler.
Disgusting human being.
Thanks.
Keep up the good work.
Yeah, I mean, listen, the guy's a total hypocrite.
The you know, Putin's good or Putin's bad.
Ukraine's good are Ukraine's bad.
He will build the wall or not.
Or he'll replace Obamacare or he won't.
Or it it, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what he says.
We don't really know what he believes.
I believe he basically believes nothing.
He believes whatever's convenient to say at
the time.
But yeah, and I actually remember the opposite
also, because there were times while Trump
was there that he called the White House beautiful.
And then now that Biden's there says that
it's a dump and it's been disgraced or whatever.
Cheri, I just wouldn't worry about it.
Don't worry about what Trump says on the White
House.
Last email is from Kate.
Kate says you might want to be careful, citing
a dictionary as a prescriptive reference,
this is a common error.
A dictionary is a descriptive tool, not a
prescriptive one.
It describes the language that existed at
the time of publication.
Using the dictionary to say the dictionary
says X means Y isn't helpful.
The dictionary doesn't tell people what to
use now.
It tells you what people used then.
Well, I mean, listen.
That's totally fair.
When I say I looked up the acceptable pronunciations
of such a word, and here's what the dictionary
says, you could say.
Well, those were acceptable at the time the
dictionary was written, but I think that that
actually sort of goes to my point, which is
absent that then any pronunciation would be
acceptable because at the end of the day,
it's just what people are doing.
It would be you.
You would better be able to justify.
No, no.
The pronunciation of electoral is appropriate
because it's what I use.
It's kind of an endless loop.
So I think when it comes to accepted pronunciations
it, I think it's OK to look at the dictionary.
Um, but I do understand how looking at the
dictionary for definitions like, you know,
when Jesse Lee Peterson said to me, What is
a man?
The dictionary may not reflect the political
and cultural realities of the time.
I think that that's fair.
And I appreciate the comment from Kate.
We have a great voice.
We have a great bonus show coming up.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com to
get instant access.
Speaker 2: We will see that.